in this QuickStart we'll install the
Google Cloud SDK initialize it and run
core g-cloud commands from the
command-line before you begin make sure
you have a Google cloud platform project
you can use and that you have Python and
the Google Cloud SDK installed on your
system begin by using the G cloud and
Nick command to setup the SDK this will
prompt you to log in and after will open
a web browser for you to do so if you
choose Y log into your Google user
account by following the on-screen
prompts to grant permission access to
Google cloud resources back in the
command line select a cloud platform
project to use and if you have the
Google compute engine API enabled you
can choose a default compute engine zone
after running these steps g-cloud init
confirms that you have successfully
completed the necessary set of steps to
view information about your SDK
installation run the following commands
use g-cloud off list to display accounts
whose credentials are stored locally use
g-cloud config lists to see the
properties of your active SDK config use
g-cloud info to view a summary of
details about your cloud SDK
installation including installed SDK
components the active user account and
more finally you can use g-cloud help to
view information about G cloud commands
and other topics
[Music]